opposition leader raila odinga and he
supporters in Nairobi trying to find
their way to the city center protesters
were heading to the president's office
and state house they did not get far
this is a protest against the rising
cost of basic Commodities inflation
taxes and electoral reforms
in all position areas like this one
police were prepared they couldn't off
all roads but that did not stop the
demonstrators several people were
arrested including politicians the
protesters are saying they will not give
up until their demands are met they are
calling this a revolution
life is hard the economy is doing badly
basic commodity prices have skyrocketed
the president said he would reduce
prices in the first 100 days but he has
not done much
we give President William Ruto the
mandate to rule we thought he will make
things easier we woke up Ali to go vote
for him next time I might not even
bother to go vote like
odinga says the protesters across the
country will continue he's organized
similar ones over the years
in 2018 he organized demonstrations for
months after a disputed election in
2017. that election was won by former
president Uhuru Kenyatta Kenyatta
yielded to opposition demands and made a
political choose after it became
difficult to run the government
now the protesters and their leaders say
this is not the end and they won't stop
until President William Ruto and his
government listen to what they're saying
Catherine soy Al Jazeera Nairobi